I mean I think this question of how we
live in a way that is responsible given
the planetary situation right of
ecological crisis and four billion
people rising into you know the middle
class and several billion more in real
trouble over the next 20 years it's a
big fundamental question Alex Stephan is
a leading voice on social innovation for
a sustainable future he is the editor of
world-changing 2.0 a user's guide to
innovative tools that are transforming
cities and suburbs into green prosperous
communities and providing bold answers
for the billions struggling to achieve a
high quality of life in the developing
world we can't sacrifice you know if
what we do is frame this whole
discussion in a way that's about what we
have to give up and what we have to lose
and what we have to retreat from I don't
believe it will work here and it
certainly won't work in places where
people are saying hey you guys have
already created this problem now you're
telling us we can't even have a basic
level of prosperity we hear a lot about
for example China's pollution promise
right but a very significant portion of
China's greenhouse gas emissions for
example our greenhouse gas emissions to
make things that then come here to be
sold
so in a way we are responsible for those
missions Stefan believes that in our
globally interconnected world cities
will be at the center of change and a
sustainable future there's a massive
remaking of what cities are going to
meet and developing so I think that it's
a time when we have to look at cities
not as something that are long
established and unchanging rather it's
real epicenters of transformation
you know there is the there is a
question of how do you actually make
that happen and how do you make it
happen right now and that's a larger
question especially here in North
America with the fact that the
alternative has been extremely profit we
are still building suburbs we are still
selling SUVs we are still running our
economy on oil because the people who
make those things and sell those things
make enormous profits off them but there
is change underway change that will
transform the urban landscape we are
about to see a wave of battles around
smart growth in metropolitan politics
about energy use about fuel standards
mileage standards and other
performance-based attributes of cars and
buildings and other things that are
gonna really fundamentally put people
who are advocating for bright green
cities as the future in direct
opposition to people who are advocating
for more of the status quo of sprawl and
high energy use Stefan believes he has
the blueprint for change how do you
start thinking about how to bring
solutions to bear to really radically
change the nature of the future part of
the idea behind really starting to talk
about bright green solutions was to
emphasize that the future can be both
green and bright right that it's we
don't need you know to think about this
in terms of decline and in terms of you
know the erosion of things we love or
our quality of life or sacrifice that
there are better ways to think about it
so we invent a new model of what
prosperity can look like then there's
another game in town and those four
billion people who are coming up rising
out of poverty can choose to emulate
that getting to bright green requires
systemic changes in the way we think
about the future the reason why I say
that the biggest barrier to building a
bright green future maybe in our heads
is that most of the time when we think
about the way things can be we in fact
think about the way things are if you
think in terms of the system as it
exists now being a given it's really
hard to imagine the kind of shifts that
we need to see happening and you get
into a situation where you start to
do what we call the swamp right where
you start to go oh well the system as a
whole can't change right everybody's
still gonna drive everywhere so let's
see if we can't invent you know a carbon
neutral car right thinking that that
will solve the problem
of course unfortunately it doesn't solve
the problem it's not a big enough shift
to actually get us where we need to go
thinking in terms of that established
system also has the difficulty of
locking us into decisions that we maybe
don't want to actually be making if we
had a different system we could in fact
change that game right we know that it's
possible for example to rebuild our
cities so there are more compact
communities with more choices in terms
of how people get around more
walkability
more access to things one needs nearby
it means that people drive less people
tend to use less energy in their homes
they tend to be able to live in smaller
spaces much more comfortably they can
really spend less money on stuff because
if you have a you know 2,000 square foot
home instead of a 5,000 square-foot home
you don't need to buy as much crap right
and so in general compact communities
facilitate all sorts of better decisions
Stephon believes technology and
information can help us change the way
we think about and use energy we know
that bringing intelligence to
decision-making into systems and
transparency for users into what's
happening with those systems changes the
way people act right that when we are
able to measure things for instance we
use them differently when you bring an
energy meter inside the house and you
can see their energy use on a daily
basis their energy use drops somewhere
between 7 and 12 percent without
anything else happening in the house so
for example smart grids which allow
energy users to essentially network with
one another and their utility much the
same way that people network with
information on the Internet
right so you can have a smart meter that
both tracks how much energy you're using
coming in and helps you use that energy
more effectively but also helps you feed
energy back into the system if you have
what's called net metering
so it can if you have a solar panel on
your roof when you're generating more
energy with your solar panel than you
need it feeds it back in the system and
your energy meter run backwards right
that's a pretty cool piece of technology
you can add that as well to electric
cars they in effect are big batteries on
wheels and when you have a whole bunch
of batteries hooked up to you know a
smart grid you end up in a position
where you have enormous amounts of
stored energy that when you have these
energy surges and peaks and demand can
be fed back into the system right and
then can be recharged when there's less
need for the energy when energy is
cheaper which basically means you don't
need to build as many power plants you
don't need to have as much centralized
energy running that system yet
technology alone is not the answer to a
sustainable future there is I think a
real tendency which is unfortunate to
assume that because we are making
technological progress in terms of
better understanding various capacities
of technologies and materials and so
forth that we are necessarily making
progress towards sustainability that's
not always the case it's also true that
some of these things potentially have
some very severe ecological and social
costs of their own that we haven't yet
recipe right there is some preliminary
data that suggests that certain
nanomaterials may not be safe for
instance that said there are also a
series of fields in which we're seeing
innovation that would appear to maybe
have more potential for good vennett's
yet delivering I think that one of the
real places that that's happening is in
terms of ubiquitous computing right the
idea that more and more things will have
computer technology embedded in them
right
have the ability to measure things and
communicate what they're measuring or
what they're seeing what they're feeling
right and the sort of social
technologies that that we've seen emerge
which are really still - in their
infancy and we've a vaccine already some
great examples of people coming together
in networks and working collaboratively
to deliver you know medical
breakthroughs to design new products to
come up with new software that works
better and it's really available I mean
there's there's more and more examples
of people working together in an
open-source manner to solve problems
world changing 2.0 offers a template for
enacting a bright green future for
everyone
fundamentally we know what makes us
happiest - it's good relationships with
people meaningful work you know sense of
belonging a sense of security and safety
interesting
and right now much of much of our lives
mouthing requiring stuff that gets in
the way
I think we're gonna start to see instead
on a shift towards those things
themselves has the goals right I also
think that we're gonna start to see
something else which is that
fundamentally you can't lead a good life
an ethically good life a life that feels
good and know that you are depriving
future generations of the opportunity to
live that way as well
for more information on the visions of a
sustainable world program at the Yale
School of Forestry and environmental
studies please visit environment
yale.edu slash visions